[Music]
I've known about dr. booth for a long
time I think like most people we heard
about him from Instagram following his
work since he first got on Instagram he
posted on Instagram I think I actually
like have been following along for seven
years which is crazy I was first
introduced to dr. Wu through my very
dear friend virtual Apple he said if
you're in LA and you want to get to
tattoo you you gotta go see dr. Wu
he's the magician
[Music]
right now we are inside the free hand
hotel within the hotel one on the second
floor and an old land marked in historic
room which we've turned into the George
Washington bar I was out in LA and I
wanted to get a tattoo and I reached out
to Virg I said hey man I'm in LA where
should I get to me he said if you're in
LA you want to get a tattoo you you
gotta go see dr. Wu I had not even heard
there was a really special experience of
getting to his parlor and the way that
his hideaway suite in LA is set up my
first time going to hideaway I was given
instructions to go to the Hollywood
Roosevelt Hotel wait in the lobby and
somebody would come get me we're sitting
there the whole time while I was waiting
and I was thinking how much cooler is
this waiting area then some other tattoo
parlors I've been to we're walking
through some back service hallways and
we pop out side and we come upon this
wooden door and we enter into woozworld
these are all these elements that make
his la studio I have a hotel in New York
and I have the puzzle pieces to recreate
this if he's interested I could recreate
hideaway in New York
fast forward here we are we've recreated
hideaway today I'm gonna get a lily
skate placed upon my enormous Lea huge
muscular by self by the famous dr. woo
that's pretty good right I mean I'm
gonna be happy with whatever the hell
you do dr. Lu on your license does it
say doctor no okay
I think that would piss real doctors off
why dr. Lu cuz he's the only one that
could handle something like this
he's the only one that won't blow it out
on the stem he can make a circle better
than anybody I've ever seen and any he
has a way of making your idea better
than what it was
the celestial geometric lines and super
angular spherical compositions those are
kind of my thing fine line black and
gray single you know
it's a style that's been around for a
long time my mentor championed it it's
not something that I invented I think
maybe it's something I just introduced
to a broader audience with my own style
version of it his technique is much more
discrete
he creates vignettes of exceptional
detail in such microscopic versions it
blows my mind the artistic creativity
and abilities and he does it with such a
gentle hand you can tell that it's him
immediately dr. Wu is one of the best
tattoo artists
[Music]
I would became a fan of receiving
tattoos
I loved up the art and the designs that
other tattooers were making I was in
variant design and drawing but never in
a tattoo aesthetic direction I was too
intimidated when I was younger to think
that I could ever become a tattoo artist
[Music]
when I started getting heavily into
collecting tattoos and hanging out with
Mark Mahoney and the people at shamrock
I was already in my early 20s I got a
little Saturn behind my ear
nothing I I saw dr. Wu's Saturn on his
ear and I was like oh that looks awesome
I'd like one like that so most of my
tattoos are not symbolically important
but they're really beautiful
spur the moment most of my other tattoos
have been sort of the standard parlor
experience and the Hideaway experience
is definitely something that's special
and unique it's not just getting the
tattoo but it's really designing it what
dr. Luu hideaway is my first studio that
I opened up outside of leaving shamrock
and it was kind of my den I guess and
the idea was just I can do my work there
and have lines be comfortable and
friends come through and hang and it's
just more of a space that was
inspirational and you know you felt like
you can create there
my upbringing into this world was a
proper classic Street tattoo shop so
there was no frills there's no like the
wheat consultations and reviewing as
much it's just you coming you tell me
what you want and then we work it out
right there you're on the spot you know
in that moment what you want I like you
know the idea of the spirit of my spot
in LA kind of floating around from city
to city around the world bringing the
same you know vibe that I bring all you
really need is your tattoo machine and
you can go anywhere
[Music]